yeah so to explain off-screen uh we just
found out that these two went to the
same kind of school together
um and they know each other as like
childhood friends or something like that
so do you guys want to explain that what
happened with that well
um well like the japanese community in
australia like
the parents there send like their kids
to like this thing called saturday
school so we have school
on saturdays from around 10 to like 1pm
and then um yeah like we were in
different classes because
you were like in a higher grade then
yeah i think i'm two years older than
you yeah yeah yeah
so but i was in the same class as hers
older sister yeah about seven years
or something yeah and because like and
again because like the school is so
community is so small you naturally hang
out with kids
who are younger than you and older so
yeah like i would
see shoe in like the playground and
stuff it's like the meme where like
every asian knows each other but it's
actually true
every japanese person knows each other
yeah so like
yeah so not only did i go to i was in
the same class as her sister but like
yeah we used to like
hang out like everything not too often
yeah not too often but
like we had so many mutual friends that
i think it's just like naturally we knew
each other okay
yeah so uh and now she's an anime voice
and now you both work in the anime
industry
yeah i gotta ask like in in this like
japanese community were there
many people who wanted to work in the
anime industry because you know how it
is with like the weeb culture he's like
you see an anime fan and they're like oh
i want to work an anime like all right
we
all right but like what was it like for
like the japanese community
i don't know i mean i think at that
point i
wasn't even really thinking about that
at all
i'm too busy enjoying the weebles
yeah exactly so it's like i don't know
because i think even back then like i
knew i always wanted to like
live and work in japan yeah but i think
like the whole like anime industry side
of things was
just kind of like a dream yeah so
mystical no one knows anything well
that's the thing right it's like i
wouldn't like back then i was like how
do you even like
begin to try and get into an industry
like yeah right so it's like
you know if i end up working in it it's
like cool but like it wasn't like i was
chasing the weeb dream yeah like i'm
definitely gonna like
work for kyoto animation well i work for
studio
well it's like no but um i mean i don't
know did you
know anybody like what was it like for
you like did you always wanted to become
an anime voice actress or whatever for
me i was like
oh i was like opposite to you and i was
like i really want to become a voice
actor and i'm going to become a person
oh you're all like okay
yeah yeah and so um but i didn't know
anyone around me who
wanted to become like you know someone
who was in the anime industry so
like for me it was just me like yeah
yeah
come to japan to get into this industry
because i think the majority of like
the people at our saturday school
weren't even really like thinking
to be in japan yeah yeah because like
even to this day like most of my
japanese friends from that saturday
school most of them still
live in sydney and that's just like yeah
normal english-speaking
everyday job kind of thing so it's like
yeah i think she and i are the weird
ones
i mean i i already hear the word
saturday school and i'm like you guys
are crazy
my god five days of school is it was
enough for me one more day in the
weekend nah
mother mother i am not attending another
school day okay
i fought like hell to get out of sunday
school yeah my biggest battle of life
i mean to be fair like i personally
didn't even see it as
like a school for me it was more just
like a hangout to like hang out with
like all
right they [ __ ] tricked you they sold
you on another day of school
i mean like again like it's it's not
like i didn't learn anything
right like obviously especially when you
get because the school we had it started
from kindergarten so like what you're
like four or five years old
all the way up until ninth grade when
you're brainwashed indoctrinated
i'm just hearing indoctrination here get
them out get them all they're young
build a habit and they'll just they'll
love it
they'll learn to love it it's like
stockholm syndrome